liz truss is elected as the leader of
the conservative and unionist party a
new tory leader the new prime minister
soon in the most challenging of times
liz trusts promising action on the big
crises facing the country i will deliver
a bold plan to cut taxes and grow our
economy
i will deliver on the energy crisis
dealing with people's energy bills but
also dealing with the long-term issues
we have on energy supply are you our
next chancellor outside allies who will
be appointed to the cabinet later today
probable chancellor quasi quatern and
possible foreign secretary james
cleverley
former leadership candidates turned
trust cheerleaders also likely to be
offered jobs
rishi sunak supporters say they'll back
the new prime minister and her policies
but they're still sounding cautious so
you're on board with things like cutting
national insurance now you could vote
for that
if that's what the prime minister brings
forward yes i can support that and it
will of course be really important to
ensure that whatever decisions are taken
on tax
that
they don't impact on inflation or
add on excessively to to borrowing
others who resigned over boris johnson
reserving judgment what do you make of
the results
clear win we'll have to wait and see if
she can deliver but she said the right
things delivery and unity very important
this trust's margin of victory is
decisive but this isn't the trouncing
that some were predicting rishi sunak
supporters here say they now want the
party to come together but a lot of
things have been said in the last six
weeks that can't be quickly undone or
forgotten but liz trust's first task
today will be to travel here balmoral
and aberdeenshire to meet the queen and
be asked to form a government then the
new prime minister will speak to the
country from downing street a focus in
that speech too likely to be on the cost
of living senior tories already making
clear what they'd like to see on support
for rising energy bills i wouldn't give
a very big package to everybody because
that's simply racking up already huge
debt and it's going to have to be paid
back sometimes so i think those at the
bottom of the pile is where i would
concentrate my resources
it's been a bruising leadership contest
but with problems piling up for the new
prime minister the real work begins now
rob powell sky news in westminster